hey guys Pete here once again there's a
ton of new news rolling out of Spain in
Northern Ireland about the upcoming
season of Game of Thrones so it's time
for a spoiler report if you don't like
production spoilers or speculation based
on characters who we know are filming
scenes for season 7 you're probably
going to want to stop watching right now
be sure to check out my other recent
Game of Thrones videos though because
I'm having a giveaway and you can learn
about how to earn an entry in that
everyone else stick around to the end of
this video for more details with that
out of the way let's get down to
business so the number of photos and
stories coming out of the filming
locations for season 7 is just huge this
year it's a lot to keep up with actually
so every so often I comb through all the
articles and put everything together for
you guys in the last video I made we saw
a bunch of photos from actors both old
and new returning to Belfast and this
week we got more first maester wolkan is
back on the set he was the boltons
Meister in season 6 which you might
remember sent out those Ravens lying
about ramsay killing ruth
ideally masers have no political
loyalties to the houses they serve so we
can assume that he'll just stay at
Winterfell to serve the Starks now that
the Bolton's are no more it's been a
while so in case you forgot the stark
children grew up at Winterfell with
maester Luwin who died in season 2 OSHA
gave him the gift of mercy before
leaving the godswood to head north with
bran and Rickon
now that the Starks are occupying
Winterfell again they will need a
reliable maester to tend to the Ravens
and care for the sick or wounded there
have been a lot of set photos from two
locations and a confirmation of a set
that they're going to return to in
season 7 I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
this right but Zumaya
is a seaside location where they have
built up like a set above the coast in
Spain there's been a lot of casting
reports from this location so we know
they're hiring a good number of extras
they're asking for military experience
in the casting calls so I imagine
there's going to be a battle they're not
exactly clear who will be involved
though and for now I'm just hoping that
we'll learn more once shooting is
underway the location they're returning
to is called the dark hedges in Northern
Ireland which is a great-looking
tree-lined Lane the site is used for the
Kings Road which is the road that's
matches between Castle black at the wall
all the way through King's Landing to
storms and in the south with so many
characters mobile at the end of season
six there are a number of candidates of
who could actually show up there
I'll leave the speculation to you guys
so just tell me in the comments which
character or characters you think will
be on the kingsroad in season seven the
last location is really exciting in my
opinion and is also the source of our
first big spoiler Teleca the Roman ruins
found in Spain has been the source of a
lot of speculation since it was named as
a location months ago the best guess now
is that'll be used as the dragon pit
which is based on previous spoilers that
have been released if you aren't sure
what the dragon pit is you can check my
video about its history to learn more
and why it's going to be so important in
season 7 there have been a ton of photos
taken here showing different
construction and details about when they
will be closing the location off to the
public for shooting more exciting than
that is that Watchers on the wall
reported that they have it from a
reliable source that that indeed this
location will involve Danny at the
dragon but they're also reporting that
that she'll be meeting with several
familiar characters there according to
their source Danny will be meeting with
Davos and Brienne of Tarth in the first
video I made about the dragon pit I was
excited because the location meant that
Danny would be in King's Landing this
news is something I never expected since
Davos is John's man and Breanna Brienne
is sworn to Sansa so basically we are
confirmed that we're going to be getting
a meeting between the Targaryen dragon
and the king and the north northern
advisors does it confirm an alliance
well not necessarily but it does remind
us of just how fast we are moving
towards the end of this series it also
hints that the three heads of the Dragon
will all be connected before season 7 is
over fellow Ramsay who plays Lyanna
Mormont has also been spotted on set in
the last video I posted the Instagram
photo that the actor who plays tour Mun
posted on Instagram but these photos
show her on set in full costume there's
no doubt that the little bear will steal
her scenes but we can only speculate on
what her character will be up to the
only additional hints we have that
aren't related to the next thing in
lunatic
is that these photos were taken on a day
where the actors who play Jon Snow
Brienne and Davos were photographed on
set as well I don't know about you but
I'm feeling a king in the north who has
lady Mormont and Davos at his side Arya
has also been photographed on set and
the photos are the source of some pretty
epic speculation first of all you'll
notice that she's dressed in a very
similar fashion to what we saw Lyanna
Mormont wearing that is to say she's
wearing traditional northern wear it's
also been confirmed that the photos
amazing in Bello were taken on the same
day so if I was feeling a king in the
north with Liana and Davos I decide then
I don't even know what the word to use
to describe the feeling I'm having for a
scene like that that includes Arya we
haven't seen Arya dressed like a stark
and far too long so we have to ask if
this is confirmation that you know she's
shooting scenes and Winterfell it's hard
to imagine that she would just randomly
decide to change her look in the
Riverlands where she would most likely
want to fly under the radar she
definitely doesn't look like a girl on
the run so let's cross our fingers that
this means she is joined back up with
Jon at the very least I don't want to go
down a rabbit hole because they're a
bunch of other characters still to talk
about I just want to point out that the
show isn't filmed in chronological order
there's a lot of stuff that Arya could
actually be up to you know in this
season before she actually gets to any
scenes that are connected with these
photos so let's be real before the end
of season 7 we will see her as a
reunited member of House Stark of
Winterfell we'll have to wait and see
how she gets there and if you know the
years on the road have changed her so
much that this will be a hard transition
either way I'm pumped in the next set of
Aria photos at surface we got another
twist to consider this photo shows the
actors in the trailer and we see bran
and Arya in makeup at the same time I
will get to bran a little later but
could this mean that we will see all the
living Starks back together firstly I
don't think so in season 7 but you have
to admit that it's cool to see them
together even if it is only in the
makeup chairs watches on the wall
reported that it looks like bran is
leaving the set while Arya is still in
costume and I tend to agree which means
that they're probably filming unrelated
scenes we haven't seen emilia clarke in
any of the photos that came out but she
imposed some of you know emilia clarke
did post photos and video from the set
depicting the bad weather she's been
filming it beyond that we haven't seen
anything else but if you don't follow
her on instagram i would suggest she
doesn't post that often but she does
post some cool behind the scenes like
non-spoiler stuff
dolorous EDD is a great character that
we don't really talk about much there
was so much going on the end of season 6
she might have actually overlooked the
fact that he is the new Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch
as an unlikely hero he's left with a
small ragtag bunch at Castle black and
sources are reporting that Ed will be
shooting a scene with bran for season 7
this would seem to indicate that bran
will pass through the wall which many
have speculated will cause major
problems since he has been marked by the
night king most of us believe that the
wall will fall at the end of season 7 in
fact I made a whole video about it and I
think Brandon Dolores ed talking is a
pretty sure sign this is going to happen
whether or not John would have sent
reinforcements to Ed by that point is up
that you know it's up in the air but at
least we know bran will make it there
the final spoiler that's come out
involves two characters that I'm not
sure how exactly we'll end up together
los siete Ramos is reporting that Jon
Snow and Theon Greyjoy
will be reuniting face to face in season
seven they say that this reunion will be
taking place south of Winterfell which
means I don't have any clue as to what
the circumstances that will bring them
together will be remember Theon decided
to head back to the Iron Islands after
saving Sansa from Rock Ramsay because he
feared what would happen when John saw
him now it looks like the reunion is
inevitable so we'll just have to
speculate on what will happen when they
meet to sum it all up a lot of
characters are coming together in season
seven to this point everyone has been
spreading out since the very first
season and it looks like we've finally
reached the point where their stories
have started to bring them all back
together on top of the Theon and Jon
reunion it looks like Jon and Arya will
also be meeting up that's huge because a
you know we it was a pretty exciting
thing to see Santa and Jon get together
and they really didn't have any strong
connection Ari and Jon are the two
closest of the remaining stark siblings
so that is awesome to think about then
we have Daenerys meeting with Davos and
Brienne and
and making it to Castle black to meet
with the Lord Commander the lower said
the possibilities are almost maddening
so let me know what you guys think the
timeline will look like in the comments
to follow up on some of my previous
videos if John is going to meet Theon in
the south this could confirm that your
on will be capturing Yara instead of
Theon there was talk about a battle at
sea between two then you know the two
different factions of the Greyjoy family
where you're on would take one of the
siblings captive so I think it's likely
now that that will turn out to be our my
last video I mentioned the theory from
because geek that speculated about a
northern boy we saw in photos who she
thought might be a young little thing
that doesn't seem to be the case now
while the idea of the red-haired actress
we saw on set was not a stand-in for
Santa part that part was right we found
out that she is probably playing Alice
Karstark instead of a young Catelyn not
sure that means about the boy's identity
but he's probably involved in a present
time scene rather than a flashback no
new news on Lannister since the last
video and we've seen Littlefinger
spotted on the set along with characters
like Podrick and Brienne but we haven't
got any new information on what he might
be up to
tormund Giantsbane has also been spotted
on the scene and as far as I know we
haven't had any new Gendry sightings
since he showed up in you know in the
airport about a month ago there was one
photo that showed Gwendoline Christie
getting her call sheet at the end of the
day when you zoomed in on it you could
see that it involves a scene with a
working title of the big tree and some
other vague details are also there like
the you know the director of that
particular episode I'm guessing the big
tree refers to the gods what at
Winterfell which could mean just about
anything so how let you guys decide what
you think it has to do with the other
news that's about it for now let me know
in the comments what you think it all
means what are your thoughts on a full
stark reunion how do you think Arya will
respond to a reunion with John do you
think John will be able to forgive Theon
for his past transgressions and mistakes
what exactly do you think Davos Brienne
and Danny will discuss at the dragon pit
in King's Landing and how do you imagine
it's possible that those three
characters could get together right
under Queen Circe's nose I'll leave all
links to all the videos that I mentioned
in
comments like we want to go back and see
the one on the wall the dragonpit or any
of the other season seven spoiler videos
please leave a like on this video if you
thought it was good and don't forget to
subscribe now that mr. robot is over I
started doing Westworld videos and the
show is turning out to be really good so
far
so make sure you check out the show and
make sure you check out my recap and
reviews if you're watching it lastly the
book giveaway is still going on for
subscribers so why don't you jump on the
bandwagon right now when I hit 18,000
subscribers I'll pick one comment from
one of my recent Game of Thrones videos
and send a copy of a night of the Seven
Kingdoms by george RR martin to that one
lucky subscriber you can enter as many
times as you want by going back to watch
my other game the thrones videos and
leaving a comment there
you should watch those anyway so it's a
win-win situation thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon